hey guys let's talk about jeans denims
did you know that the word jeans comes
from the word
jen which is the french word for the
city of genoa
now even though around 450 million pairs
of jeans are being sold in america each
year and more across the globe most
people don't know how to wear their
jeans correctly so in this video i want
to share seven ways of how you might be
wearing your jeans the wrong way let's
get to it
[Music]
all right now the first mistake that a
lot of guys make is that they wear super
skinny jeans or tight jeans when it
doesn't fit in with their body type for
example if you have skinny legs and you
wear skinny jeans you might look like a
guy who is top heavy or
like a humpty dumpty with these
toothpick legs it doesn't look good
now guys with smaller ankles and coughs
they don't look good with just normal
jeans either well in most cases because
then you have all that extra material on
your lower legs so instead just buy and
wear
slim fit jeans that will fit in with
your legs a lot better
wearing the wrong color now most guys
they like black and blue jeans right
including myself i like it but the
problem is a lot of guys choose the
wrong colors when it comes to the rest
of the outfit for example don't wear a
blue color shirt or sweater that is a
similar blue to your blue jeans because
it just looks terrible
now let me just say this this video this
is just my own opinion alright so if you
want to go ahead and do something that
i'm saying don't do this then it's fine
you go ahead and you do your thing
because it's your life
but that doesn't mean that other people
will see you the same way as you see
yourself
now something else is my opinion never
wear light blue jeans with dark brown or
black shoes or tees lighter colored
jeans will look better with lighter
shoes and clothes that can compliment it
it is also a good idea to wear darker
clothes with darker jeans
big baggy jeans but now you have to know
this and it doesn't matter if you're
small medium or if you're a big guy if
you are going to wear big packagings you
are going to look sloppy and
unprofessional to a lot of people all
you need is a pair of jeans that just
fit in really well with your lower body
that's it when it comes to your waist if
you can fit two fingers between your
gene and your skin it's a perfect size
jeans that are too long i see there's a
lot of younger guys who go to the store
and then i choose jeans that are too
long for them
the thing is don't focus just on the
waist of the jeans but focus on the
length of it as well and just in case
you didn't know this you can get the
same waist size in different lengths for
example if you look at the size it will
usually show you two numbers like a 34
36 the 34 is the waist size and the 36
the inseam meaning the length so if a 36
in seam is too long for you just buy a
34 if you don't want to go and buy
jeans if you don't have money then just
change the ones that you already have
just cuff the old ones according to your
leg length i've made a full video about
it if you want to check it out after
this video
[Music]
high-rise jeans now of course you don't
really get this with guys but you do get
those certain jeans that just
have too much fabric at the bottom area
and this causes the fabric to hang and
it might look like you have a saggy bum
and it just it just looks terrible
that is why it's important never to just
go and buy jeans but to always fit them
on first to make sure that they fit you
look there are some guys with big bumps
out there and some with well not so big
because it's just all got to do with
your dna right so if you don't have big
rear cheeks then don't buy jeans that's
got too much material at the back
[Music]
hanging jeans you know what i'm talking
about those saggy jeans that are hanging
below your butt
in fact why not just walk in your
underwear because if that's all that i
see because your jeans are there on your
ankles what's the point
of wearing jeans
and think about this
nobody wants to see your underwear there
are kids in public places as well man
oh yeah before i forget if you're new
here to my channel my name is daniel and
welcome to dlm men's lifestyle if you
haven't subscribed yet please consider
it and also click that notification bell
here so you won't miss any of my next
videos i would really love the support
now let's move on to the next tip
not wearing a belt or wearing the wrong
type of belt now this of course it
depends on your age but i would say men
above 25 should not really just wear
jeans without a belt anymore but you
should choose a belt that will fit in
with your clothing style for example the
belts with those big buckles really
don't look good anymore or unless you're
a cowboy from texas or you're a guy
living in the country and then don't
wear the wrong color belt for example a
brown belt should never be worn with
black shoes
or a black belt with brown shoes
it's good to always remember that the
color of your shoes should always match
the color of your belt
if you want more tips on style or
self-improvement tips and check out
these videos here and i'll see you there
and always remember before you go
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys